I'm just going to Jump Right In what has
it been like um not just playing Father
and Son but also playing these two like
mythological characters in this uh in
the series
um I thought it was awesome Playing
Father and Zen I think it was cool to
see a new take on The Monkey King
because I think most people know Monkey
King from the Journey to the West story
and his kind of Journey from being you
know a rambunctious rebellious young
monkey that's stubborn as hell
um and then goes on this journey and
becomes enlightened in the end and so
what we're seeing now is the after
effects of that Journey it's much later
now it's like 4 000 years later he's a
little bit older he's a father now and
he's got this son Who's acting a lot
like he did when he was little right and
so
um he's you know he has had this
internal struggle whether it's like do
you control this kid and allow him to
grow on his own or do you
um try to protect him from and keep him
from making these mistakes and it was
really cool to be working with Jimmy on
this you know Jimmy first time working
on an American project reminded me of
like the first time I worked in Asia
when my career first started and Chinese
was not my first language it's my second
language there and so you know
struggling with the language but Jimmy
like this kid is smart he's a fast
learner he he learned
um the American ways really quickly and
I think by the second or third week you
just fit right in yeah I mean Jimmy I'm
just speaking about this being your
first project
um American project at least how has the
experience been was it um was the
transition smooth well I was like
super like nervous when I first got here
and I couldn't even order in in a
restaurant and but I kind of get used to
it after two or three weeks because I've
been talking to everyone on set and
yeah they make me feel safe and like I
can talk whatever I want and don't be
afraid to make mistakes just talk and
we'll learn yeah he's incredible on the
show because there's a lot of like small
intricate comedic moments and comedy is
very hard to do in a second language but
he hits those like those beats really
well
um my favorite you know part is when
he's talking about being a confident
dude
um that that stuff he just like hits and
Nails it on the head it's amazing yeah I
think the comedy hit really well in this
um so Daniel just to speak with you
about playing I mean this is for
non-chinese people this is like a huge
mythological figure but as an Asian
American yourself was there a point in
the story where you felt like you could
relate to more of the human characters
which I would say like jyn and his
parents was there more of a point of
connection for you there oh yeah
absolutely because I think the the
relationship between subukong and Wei
Chun is very similar to you know chinhan
and Ben Wong's character right they're
they're both father-son they're both
struggling to communicate with their son
and teach them the values that they
believe in
um without being didactic about it right
but they at the same time that you know
they're they're they're both fathers
trying to figure out how to be dads
right and so those relationships are
mirror each other and they're really so
similar but then one side they're
mythological gods and one side they're
you know a Chinese immigrant family and
I think that's the beauty of the
adaptation of this this story because in
the graphic novel it's like very three
distinct story lines right you have
what's going on with Jin's character
then you have Monkey King's character
and then you have you know Keys the the
kind of problematic 90s character and
they're all they're not integrated in
the book and so what Calvin you did in
this adaptation is really put those
story lines in bring them together in
one overall tone which is really really
hard to do right to make an intimate
family moment but then a Chinese
mythological God situation feel like
it's the same thing
um the the team did an amazing job
integrating that and making it work yeah
um so I just want to talk a little bit
about those fight scenes that we see in
the show because there's one every
episode basically yeah and um I just
want to talk about what you guys did to
prep for it and Jimmy I would like to
hear if you got any tips from uh Daniel
I know he's he's got some skills well I
I have a back black belt and oh okay and
I I learned for it I learned Taekwondo
for like seven six six years
so I kind of learn pretty fast on
martial arts thing yeah yeah I think
Jimmy is pretty physically talented
because even though you might have a
black belt martial arts on screen
fighting is very different
um it's not it doesn't take on like a
traditional form and so you got to kind
of do what's best for the screen
movement and Jimmy's a good mover
um he's a good athlete not just a good
martial artist and that's really
integral to doing good on-screen
fighting but you know we had pungjong
who did the fighting in the fight
choreography for Shang Chi and so we
have that really high level you know
Hong Kong style woo shot style element
brought into this television show and it
was you know important that we spent a
lot of time and effort on it and not
just do typical television where you're
like okay we'll just do if I'd seen it
one day you know or half a day we spent
a lot of time like just that locker room
fight scene we spent a couple days doing
that fight scene
um and so you you see the results of
that and I think what's great about this
show is you have everything from Crazy
Wire work action to you know really cool
small intimate family moments between
jyn and his mom and dad they're all
happening at one time and I think it's a
kind of amazing meld of um of all these
genres together yeah I definitely think
I like the way that they were kind of
braided together in the show I feel like
it was very um it was very smooth it
doesn't seem out of place right you know
it's like you can have things going on
at the same time and it works
beautifully and I read the book after I
saw the shows because I wanted to go
into the show with like no you know
preconceived notions but I thought it
was it was a great
um it was a great way to present that
story and I just want to talk about the
special effects in the makeup a little
bit because you guys both have a lot of
Prosthetics on your face in this show
can you talk about was that annoying
like putting it on and how many hours
did you have to sit in a makeup chair to
get all that stuff on your face it's
annoying like yes yeah at the beginning
I I thought it was pretty fun because I
could be like a monkey and there's like
Harry and I always like touch the hair
and it's pretty fun but
it started get annoying because you have
to
sit there for three hours have to get to
get on set three hours early just to put
on put a special makeup on and you have
to
stay for another hour to take it off
yeah we had some painful call times with
uh that prosthetic stuff
um it's kind of the first time doing it
for me so when I agreed to do this role
I totally didn't think about that part
of it and I realized like that was a lot
of the work
um working on set with these guys was
the fun part the not fun part was
getting the makeup put on and like I
think remember Jimmy we had that we had
a 2 A.M call time so that we could be
shooting by 6 a.m uh that scene in the
first first episode in the first scene
where we're
um I'm confronting him about getting my
staff back we had to shoot that at Magic
hour so to do that we had to be up by
like 1 30 in the morning and then on in
the makeup van by 2 A.M so they could be
ready camera ready by 6am it was crazy
crazy couple of days doing that oh my
God that is insane did you sleep that
night or were you just no yeah I went to
bed at like 8 A.M probably Jimmy didn't
sleep but I went to bed at 8pm and then
I woke up at like midnight and then it
was very disorienting and strange
um but the process sucked but the way it
looked was amazing and the way it felt
on your face like it didn't feel like it
was in impinging on your acting in any
way or any kind of expression so the
eyes still felt real I was still able to
move my face without feeling restricted
so that part was actually not as bad as
I thought it was going to be it was just
the process of getting it put on and
then taking off at the end of the day
when you really want to just go home
yeah I mean it looked fantastic so I
just want to say it was it was a great
it was a great look I was surprised at
how well it came out and then just a
final question is going to be about
using you know the way Mandarin is used
in this I really enjoyed it because I
can speak Mandarin myself and getting to
hear the parents speaking and you know
the like lost and translation of like
you like the frying squid which is
getting fired what was it like getting a
script is it was it all in Mandarin were
you reading it or was it more
improvisational what was the what was
the process for that the script came as
you see it so whatever was in Mandarin
is written in Mandarin and then
whatever's in English is in English and
I really think that that's what delivers
the authentic experience of this of this
show right it really does show the
authenticity of the Immigrant experience
and what it's like to be second
generation and try to fit in where you
have this dual language going on in your
household right you your parents may be
speaking to you one language you speak
back in English
um you know and then and then with the
mythological characters it made a lot of
sense for when they're in heaven that
they're speaking Chinese but when
they're down on Earth in America they're
speaking English because they're
adaptable they can do all that so I
think it's pretty seamless and it makes
a lot of sense and I think nowadays you
know it wasn't like 15 years ago I
remember when Crouching Tiger first came
out it's like some people like oh I
don't read subtitles right but now
people it's it's not a problem at all in
fact people prefer a subtitle version
over a dub version any day a now and
whereas that wasn't the case 30 40 years
ago and then all the kids going out
watching anime now they all prefer the
original version over the dub version so
I think it's not going to be a problem
and I think again like I said it
delivers a more authentic experience of
what it's like to be you know Asian
American well I just want to thank you
both for speaking with me that's all the
time I have I really enjoyed the show I
thought you guys were both really great
and that Jimmy you were fantastic Daniel
as always fantastic thank you so much
for everybody to see this